Gillette updating its classic best a man
can get slogan for the me2 era
encouraging men to take a stand against
so-called toxic masculinity they don't
want to be held accountable it is toxic
masculinity that's not actual
masculinity toxic masculinity is tied so
closely to masculinity itself well you
hear a lot of that these days that men
should act manly without being toxic
whatever that means
boys need to be taught to soften their
edges lest they step over the line
because of all that testosterone well
that's why I think it's important at
times to highlight those moments when
men's natural strength and chivalry and
yes courage saves lives take the heroes
from two recent shootings when a gunman
opened fire at a UNC Charlotte campus
ten days ago
21-year old Riley Howell charged at him
was shot point-blank but still knocked
the shooter off his feet then there's 18
year old Kendrick Castillo he lept from
his desk Tuesday at a Colorado stem
school when a shooter entered the
classroom while he confronted the
suspect with little regard for his own
life others rushed to safety
Kendrick tragically was killed but
because of his bravery
well something Kendricks father
remembered about him it's no surprise
that if danger was facing him he would
approach it oh my god I bawled when I
saw that today unbelievable young man
but what possesses men to act this way
well for answers I want to bring a dr.
Drew Pinsky we've talked about these
issues before dr. drew but these two
cases I just got goosebumps like hearing
you know the dad his his loss his
sadness but the heroism and the
sacrifice from young men 16 17 18 years
of age I'm not here to speak their own
story their own truth but I'm incredible
yeah there is a tendency for the males
to turn their aggression which is what
people worry about with toxic
masculinity through an aggression into a
positive impulse whether they're landing
at the beach in Omaha or whether they're
rushing
a shooter there is a natural tendency
that they they actually learned through
something called rough-and-tumble play
that's automatic in young males where
they learn to sort of modulate their
aggression but they also learn how to
turn it up so they know what it's time
to bring it on yeah but so much in
society today let's face it discourages
men from believing there's a natural
impulse to be chivalrous or to be this
type of show this type of physical
courage if you say physical courage well
you're stereotyping and obviously women
can it can be courageous and our
courageous everyday so you see what I'm
saying there's a push and pull with this
masculinity deal right I have to agree
with you it's not an exclusive it's
another exclusive club it's not that
Brienne of Tarth on Game of Thrones is
not a heroic figure and the rest of the
males in there are somehow exclusively
heroic women can be heroic too it's just
there's a because of the aggression
because of the thing that makes us toxic
it also makes us do some of the things
that have pushed society forward and
also have helped people in extreme
situations where there's an
extraordinary amount of selflessness
but it's aggression ultimately it's
aggression and we're turning our
aggression on an aggressor and it's okay
then yeah there was another issue here
with one of the suspects in the Colorado
school shooting which is being
overlooked in some quarters it was a
transgender male in the process of
transitioning okay so from female
biologically to male and assuming
because in transition likely taking
hormones testosterone and so forth what
would that series of drugs do or how
could it affect the mental state of an
individual given how little we have as
far as information on the way these
drugs affect behavior especially the
testosterone that is correct so we have
very limited limited research on this
topic and I know of no evidence that it
turns people actually violent but when
you expose people to male levels of
testosterone
I've talked I've taken care of many many
transgender folks over the years and
whenever I particularly get sort of I
wouldn't say amused but I'm interested
in talking to the male to female to male
transition patients because they always
say the same thing there oh my god I had
no idea you were dealing with this and I
point out to them not only have we been
dealing with this chemical in our system
God God saw fit to give us this at 13
want to read some maybe I want to read
the summon this is from dr. Paul McHugh
and dr. Paul ruse they said the truth is
that this therapy may have real
long-term effects on children's physical
and psychological development whether
blocking puberty is the best way to
treat gender dysphoria remains far from
settled and it should be considered a
drastic and experimental measure Johns
Hopkins and University of Washington to
that Primeau premier researchers on this
others who use these drugs say the same
thing hey we don't we don't have
peer-reviewed studies on this yet
parents are giving kids these these
drugs before the age of 18 before they
can get real consent even we don't have
the research say you've said it you're
so you've said it that's clear that is
true and so for me to say something
conclusive about aggression and violence
I can't do it but testosterone is the
drug of aggression and so there is a
certain amount of let me glory I want to
take one quick thing that bothers me now
is that we've gotten to a position in
this country where we privilege
psychiatric symptoms over the well-being
of the individual and the community so
if this kid was having a lot of symptom
or tala gee no one was allowed to do
anything if the kid didn't want anything
done unless the parents demanded it with
the 18 year old you can't do anything
there's privilege in the law for
psychiatric symptoms that's why we have
homeless and that's why we're getting
some of these horrible violent acting
out episodes dr. Drew Pinsky always
great to see you on a Friday night any
night dr. drew you take care